today we're checking out the brand-new
air pods - that just came out now not
technically calling these the air pods -
they are calling them air pods wireless
charging case granted these are the
second edition of the air pods since
they first were announced a few years
ago and it's interesting because I don't
think I ever expected to like these as
much as I have like them so there's now
three versions of air pods that you
could buy this is the air pods with the
wireless charging case and these are
$1.99 you can get just regular air pause
without a charging case from 159 or if
you just want to use your old air pods
and just buy a wireless charging case
you can get that for 79 bucks so really
there's three different options for you
but today we're gonna be checking out
the new air pods with the wireless
charging case let's open it up it's so
nice to have a drawer over here now I
could just kind of get my things I went
with a green light today that is an ode
to the green LED charging light that
they have on the front of the air plugs
now they actually move that light from
the inside here to the front of the case
which you'll see here soon this is
really exciting the one thing I will
notice the air pods do kind of get
really disgusting after a while
traveling and just your goodness and if
you're gonna tell me that your air pods
are perfectly clean like in whatever
you're a mutant because I don't believe
it first thing we have is we've got our
little booklet here air pods some
paperwork I wonder if there's a picture
of air power in here anywhere too soon
no it's actually it's too late
[Music]
here they are you can see the light that
they moved to the front I first open the
little light is searching for my phone
okay where the heck is my phone much
like the previous version all we got to
do is open this up and it should auto
start setting up there we are
let's connect done these are so clean it
feels like they have a more gentle pull
out of the case I don't know how else to
phrase that anytime I tell Siri to play
me music she always plays Third Eye
Blind
even in my home pop video every single
time I'd be like girl play me some music
and she freakin plays Third Eye Blind
I mean Third Eye Blind is one of my
favorite bands so I'm absolutely and do
it you guys are wondering how to change
the name of your ear pods name in case
you've never done that before you don't
have to go into your bluetooth settings
click the I click the name and you can
change it there some of the things that
are different in these new air pods is
you'll get a much faster connection so
if you're switching between your phone
to your laptop and your laptop to your
phone it should switch up to two times
faster also if you're transferring a
phone call from your phone to your ear
pods it'll also transfer 50% quicker
something else that was interesting is
if you guys do play a lot of mobile
games you'll have 30% less latency in
the audio between your game and the
audio from the game to your air pods so
30% is actually a significant amount if
you think about it you'll have 50% more
talk time and you'll have hey si RI you
can actually play a song raise the
volume get directions basically anything
that you normally would be asking Siri
to do and of course the biggest
difference is the wireless charging case
so that's something that we need to test
out I've got my little Mophie charger
here so I'm gonna plug this in if you're
standing up or something you might need
to sit down because this is extremely
riveting content right now hold on
I like half-expected like my entire
world to just be flipped upside down
like HS start raining down confetti
money starts flowing from the air a
unicorn runs into my office but my ear
pods are charging wirelessly do you want
to see it again can you see it can you
even see the freaking light let me turn
the sound look it that so that's the
first look at the new airport I would
love to know from you guys do you have
air pods have you used air pods do you
want air pods as the wireless charging
case now make you want these air pods
even more I'm not sure these feel
actually do they feel heavier I keep
trying to find things that are different
and I think that I sort of have these
phantom thoughts in my mind it's like
when my Apple watch isn't on I have
phantom taps on my wrist and I look and
there's no Apple watch there so I think
that might be what's happening right now
there is nothing better than a nice new
fresh air pods case so this is my old
case it looks like it's definitely been
through some things this is the new case
the back looks very similar they moved
the little bluetooth button though up a
little bit a little bit higher so flip
these open here's the new ones here's
the old ones I'm gonna try charging my
old air pods in the new case that's also
super exciting so now I think that the
only thing left I don't even want to say
it because you guys know what I'm gonna
say
where is air power because I'm so ready
for it at this point
one thing I would do want to test is I
would like to test and see if I can hear
a difference
[Music]
this is a super scientific test right
now baby definitely do connect faster
that the new ones connected this is like
a fun race just scenes air pods just see
this new air pods
I'm also working on a wrap-up video from
the Apple event yesterday I didn't get a
chance to film that last night because I
got home so late I would love to know
what you guys thought of the Apple event
they announced the Apple card the Apple
TV plus Apple TV channels Apple arcade
Apple news plus all kinds of things
leave those in the comments below and
when I make my wrap-up video I will be
sure to feature a few of you guys well
thank you for watching I just want to
show you here is the air pods really
quick I will do a follow-up video
probably in a week air pods to a week
later video
[Music]